every single time I've stepped Inside
the Cage my profile has increased
whether it's a win or whether it's with
a loss you know a devastating knockout
sometimes doesn't even get you as much
jump in profile as a crazy fight of the
Year where you take a loss against
Justin gate M Square Garden you know
people can talk about my record all they
want yeah I'm two and three in the UFC
but I fought everybody inside the top
three or top five right I mean dude that
gagei fight was absolutely fight of the
year it's not all about the wins and the
losses and of course I can say it cuz I
haven't won every fight it's an easy cop
out for me to say hey I might not have
won I made you feel I made you want to
do more what you're doing right now
because you saw me go there with my
heart on myle go out on my shield maybe
it works out maybe it doesn't but even
if you lose you win when you're truly
operating within your passion for sure
that's why we love fighting the UFC does
it better than anybody